شكرا لك اسامه بالفعل مشاهدينا لا زلنا
معكم في تغطيتنا المستمره لتطورات المشهد
السوداني ومع استقبال اول اضواء النهار في
السودان تصاعدت اصوات الانفجارات ودوي
اطلاق النار في محيط قياده الجيش بالخرطوم
ومواقع اخرى من العاصمه وفي خضم هذه
التطورات الميدانيه تبادل الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم السريع الاعلانات حول السيطره
على هذا الموقع او ذاك فقد اعلنت قوات
الدعم السريع اسقاط طائره مسيره بقاعده
جري العسكريه شمال الخرطوم بحري فيما اعلن
الجيش السوداني سيطرته على كافه مقرات
الدعم السريع بالمدينه قبل ان يطالب
المواطنين باخلاء المنازل الواقعه في محيط
مبنى التلفزيون على صعيد اخر على صعيد
الخسائر البشريه اعلنت نقابه اطباء
السودان ارتفاع عدد قتل الاشتباكات الى 27
فضلا عن اصابه 183 اخرين فيما بدات معاناه
المدنيين تتكشف تدريجيا وسط حديثا عن
عالقنا المدارس بسبب الاشتباكات وانقطاع
للمياه والتيار الكهربائي في عدد من احياء
العاصمه الخرطوم ونتابع معكم في هذه الصور
المباشره اذا صور اطلاق النار التي
شاهدناها قبل قليل مع بزوغ فجر هذا اليوم
الثاني من المواجهه العسكريه بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع
اذا مشاهدينا كانت ليله ما تزال مستمره
طوال الليل الليله عنيفه اقصد من
المواجهات طبعا
والاصوات الرصاص الذي كان يهدا لدقائق ثم
ما يلبث ان يعود ليتفجر من جديد مع قذائف
المدفعيه في هذه المنطقه التي نشاهدها على
شاشه العربيه من محيط مقر قياده الجيش
السوداني حيث تقول قوات الدعم السريع
بانها تحاصر هذا المقر الحيوي لقياده
الجيش طبعا نتابع في هذه الاخبار العاجله
اذا اللجنه اطباء السودان المركزيه تقول
ان اجمالي القتلى بلغ سته وخمسين قتيلا
اذا الحصيله ترتفع كنا نتحدث عن حوالي 27
قتيل في هذه المواجهات ما بين الجيش
السوداني وقوه الدعم السريع الحصيله الان
ترتفع الى 56 حسب لجنه اطباء السودان
اذا مشاهدينا نحن ندخل يوما ثانيا من هذه
المواجهه الداميه ما بين المكونين العسكري
العسكريين الجيش السوداني بقياده عبد
الفتاح البرهان وقوات الدعم السريع بقياده
محمد حمدان دقلو المعروف بحمدتي
اذا نبدا في متابعه اخر التطورات مع
مراسلنا في هذه الساعه
سالم الهاشمي مراسل العربيه معي الان
مباشره من هناك سالم اهلا بك الجيش
السوداني قبل قليل قال او قبل حوالي 20
دقيقه قال اقتربت ساعه النصر ماذا يقصد
نعم بعد هذه الاشتباكات العنيفه يتحدث
السوداني على انه احكم سيطرته على كافه
المقر مقر الدعم السريع وانا ساعه الصفر
اقتربت لانه
ستنتهي المهمه في الساعات القليله القادمه
بنهايه هذا اليوم هذا ما يفهم من حديث
الجيش السوداني مع بذور فجر هذا اليوم
انطلقت اعينها هي كثيفه جدا من محيط القصر
الجمهوري وكذلك مقر القياده العامه للجيش
وهذه العيره الناريه انتشرت في سماء
الخرطوم بشكل كبير جدا الان ما زالت هذه
الاعيار الناريه كما تتابع الان متواصله
نعم طيب اخر المعطيات حول بقيه المقرات
الحيويه المقرات الرئيسيه
سالم ما المتوافر حولها من معلومات في ان
كان في القصر الجمهوري مقر الاذاعه
والتلفزيون وايضا مطار الخرطوم
مقر الاذاعه والتلفزيون السوداني بانه
احكم السيطره على مبنى الاذاعه والتلفزيون
هذا ما تم تداوله في ليل البارحه لكن صباح
اليوم الى الان دعوه التلفزيون لافت انها
ما زالت تبث ذات الاغاني منذ توقف بس
التلفزيون القومي حتى هذه اللحظات هنا في
محيط القصر الجمهوري والقياده العامه ما
زالت الاشتباكات متواصله حتى هذه اللحظه
حتى اعير الناريه وصلت الى بحري وصلت الى
المبنى الذي نحن فيه هنا
ومنذ مع بذور الفجر واثناء اداء صلاه
الفجر وصلاه مجموعه من الاعين الناريه
للمبنى الذي نحن فيه متفقنا الجيران
والحمد لله الكل بخير ولله الحمد لكن بكل
تاكيد هذه العييره الناريه متواصله
لاشتباك ما زال متواصل هذا يعني انه مازال
هناك اشتبا في تلك المناطق بين الجيش
والقوات الدعم السريع الان نستمع ايضا الى
اصوات مروحيات كذلك تحلق في تلك المناطق
او قريب منها نستمع الان الى اصوات
المروحيات ونحن هنا في منطقه بحرين انت في
خرطوم بحري صحيح طبعا وهي احدى مناطق
العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم طبعا الخرطوم
تتكون من العاصمه السودانيه يتكون من ثلاث
مناطق الخرطوم بحري والخرطوم العاصمه
واندرمان
سالم
عندما نتحدث عن تحليق مروحيات
المروحيات هنا المقصود بها التابعه للجيش
لانه حسب علمي القوات الدعم السريع لا
تمتلك مروحيات صحيح
صحيح نعم هذه المروحيه تدفع للجيش
السوداني سلاح الجو كله يطبع
للقوات المسلحه وهي من تقوم بعمليات تمشيط
وقد ذكر ذلك بالامسا ستقوم بعمليات تمشيط
للضرب كل المناطق التي تتواجد بها قوات
الدعم السريع في كل
العاصمه
وذكرت ذكر الجيش السوداني انه سيبدا
تنشيطا كذلك في المناطق المحيطه بالمناطق
كل المناطق في منطقه
هناك كانت اشتباكات عنيفه في ام درمان في
منطقه كرري وكذلك في سلاح المهندسين هذا
بالامس صباح اليوم الاشتباكات في غالبها
الان تتركز حول القياده العامه وكذلك
القصر الجمهوري حتى هذه اللحظات ما زالت
الاشتباكات متواصله
نعم طيب كان كما كنا نتابع معك في التغطيه
طوال ساعات الليل سالم
كان هناك بعض المحتجزين من الطلبه في عدد
من المناطق يعني منذ الامس يعني منذ بدايه
المواجهات هل من معلومات عن مصيرهم
لم تتواصل لدينا معلومات حتى الان عن
مصيرهم لكن المؤكد انهم ما زالوا متواجدون
في في مدرسه كابوني ولم يستطيعوا الخروج
بعد
لكن ليس لدينا معلومه عن
المؤدب الغذائيه الموجوده عندهم هل تكفيهم
او لا لم يوفر لهم مراه من حتى هذه
اللحظات للخروج من المكان الذي هم فيه
مكان المكان الذي هم عالقون فيه وهذا ما
نوهت اليه لجنه الاطباء السودان المركزيه
في هذا البيان الذي صدر عنها قبل قليل
حينما تتحدث عن انه هناك
يجب فتح ممرات امنه لاجراء المحتجزين
والمصابين ليسعافين وايضا اللجنه الاطباء
المركزيه
احدث التحديثا على عدد اجمالي القتلى من
المدنيين وهم 56 واجمالي الاصابات 595 هذا
اخر تعديل وبعد ذلك قسمت ان الخرطوم فيها
17 مدنيين وثمانيه عسكريين الاصابات
الثلاثه واثنين حاله الاصابه هذه في
الخرطوم في بحر القتلى ثمانيه حالات منهم
سبعه مدنيين وعسكري واحد الاصابات 86 حاله
اصابه ام درمان القتله 11 حاله منهم سبعه
مدنيين واربعه عسكريين والاصابات اثنين
واربعين حاله الاقاليم القتلى 25 حاله
مشمل المدنيين والعسكريين معا والاصابات
165 حاله اصابه هذا ما ذكرته السودان
المركزيه بالحديث عن لجنه الاطباء كان
هناك حديث او مناشدات سالم كذلك
يعني ايصال التيار الكهربائي او اعاده
تيار الكهربائي الى مستشفيات الخرطوم ماذا
نعرف كذلك عن انقطاع التيار الكهربائي في
العاصمه السودانيه
نعم
لم تستجب حتى الان السلطات لهذه النداءات
حينما نشدت ايضا نقابه الاطباء وهي تناسب
هيئه الكهرباء لاعاده التيار الكهربائي
لمستشفى ابراهيم
وهي تؤكد هنا ان هناك مرضى في العنايه
المكثفه ومصابون بحاجه ايضا للتدخل
الجراحي لانقطاع السياره الكهربائي في هذا
المستشفى ربما تتفاقم الحالات او ربما
تكون هناك حالات وفيات بسبب انقطاع التيار
الكهربائيه التيار الكهربائي مازال منقطع
فيها اجزاء كبيره من العاصمه الخرطوم
انقطاع ايضا الامداد المائي تذبذب في
خدمات الانترنت الان في السودان باكمله
نعم طيب سالم سادعك تجمع المزيد من
المعلومات لنا يعني هي ساعات طوال في
مراقبه الوضع هناك في السودان طبعا وبذوغ
فجر اليوم الثاني من هذا الانزلاق الخطير
في السودان ان نتابع التغطيه من هناك معنى
الصحفي والمحلل السياسي يوسف سراج الدين
سيد يوسف اهلا بك معنا في هذه التغطيه من
العربيه
كان هناك حديث من الطرفين او تجديد على
انه ساعات الفجر ستحمل حسما لهذه المواجهه
ماذا نتوقع مع بدايه هذا اليوم الثاني من
المواجهه بين الجيش والدعم السريع
نعم صباح الخير عليك وعلى المتابعين
القناه
حقيقه صحيح كما تفضلت انه كانت كل تصريحات
حتى ساعات مضت تشير الى الساعات المقبله
مع فجر هذا اليوم ستحمل بكل تاكيد يمكن
متغيرات كثيره جدا في المشهد الجاري الان
ولعله الشاهد انه منذ دقائق يمكن كان
هنالك
اشتباكات هي نفس ويمكن في محيط القياده او
داخل حتى القياده العامه القوات المسلحه
المظله مضروبه على حصار من ساعات طويله
واضح انه هذا التدوين وهذه الاشتباكات
العنيفه لها ما بعدها لربما تسهر عن بعض
الاشياء ايضا
نقل عن الجيش حديث عن قرب التبشير او ابشر
بقرب الوصول او اعلان النصر او ما الى ذلك
يعني هذه التصريحات ايضا قيلت على لسان
منسوبي الدعم السريع الساعات الماضيه
والنوم يحكمون السيطره على مؤسسات
ومرافق غايه في الاهميه وما الى ذلك واضح
انه عمليه
الاشتباكات الاخيره التي جرتها على محيط
القياده من هذه الكشافه الكبيره سيكون لها
ما بعدها ايضا الحديث عن الاشتباكات في
محيط الاذاعه والتلفزيون بمدينه
مدينه ام درمان وتحديدا حتى في في منطقه
الشمال هذه المنطقه طوال ليله امس طالما
نسمع اصوات المحذوفات بشكل كثيف ومكسر حتى
جهاز اليوم استمر هذا التجويد نسمع بين
سنيه اخرى عزيز طائرات لربما ان تكون هذه
المقصوفات في محاوله
لقطع الطريق امام اي محاولات لاستخدام
الطيران وما الى ذلك انا اعتقد ان كل ظروف
والمعطيات على على المشهد هي لا تحتمل
الدخول في حرب طويله المدى باعتبار انه
قوات الدعم السريع الان اتعرض في ساعات
الماضيه الى قصف في مغاره او الرئيسيه في
العاصمه الخرطوم فبالتالي هي باتت
[موسيقى]
في السودان الى وقف القتال فورا والعوده
للحوار كذلك كما تفضلت هناك دعوه من
السعوديه ومصر كذلك لاجتماع على مستوى
مندوبي جامعه الدول العربيه استاذ يوسف
ارجو ان تبقى معنا نبقي عينا اذا على محيط
مقر القياده العماليه الجيش السوداني اذا
كنا نتابعه طوال ساعات الليل الماضيه
واصوات الرصاص
والقذائف المدفعيه التي كانت تسمع طوال
الليله الماضيه نبقي عينا اذا على محيط
هذا المقر الحيوي في العاصمه السودانيه
ونذهب الان معكم مشاهدينا لمتابعه هذا
الفيديو الذي قالت قوته الدعم السريع انه
لقصف القياده العامه
للجيش نتابع هذا الفيديو ونعود
[موسيقى]
اذا المشاهدين
تلك الصور على ما تقول قوات الدعم السريع
بانها مشاهد لقصف مقر القياده العملي
الجيش للتذكير مشاهدينا منذ عصر الامس
يعني كان هناك تضارب في البيانات بين
الدعم السريع وما بين الجيش السوداني كان
هناك حديث على السيطره على مقرات حيويه في
السودان من قبل قوات الدعم السريعه في حين
سرع الجيش بعد ذلك لاحقا الى نفي سيطره
الدعم السريع لهذه المواقع طبعا
المحللون الذين استضفناهم من العاصمه
السودانيه طوال الساعات الماضيه
يكادون يجمعون جميعا على انه هناك حرب
اعلاميه تدور بموازاه الحرب الميدانيه
الدائره بين الطرفين العسكريين في السودان
بقياده البرهان وحميتي طبعا ونحن في خضم
يعني هذا التضارب في البيانات نبقى حذرين
في التعامل مع اي معطيات من الطرفين
بانتظار تاكيدها او نفيها بشكل قاطع طبعا
نتابع معكم طبعا الحصيله حتى الان اخر
حصيله حدثتها نقابه الاطباء السودانيين
تتحدث عن 56 قتيلا من المدنيين في عموم
السودان منذ بدايه هذا هذه المواجهه
المسلحه
منذ الامس
وكما نتابع معكم في هذه الصور المباشره من
محيط قياده الجيش العامه السودانيه في
العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم يبدو ان هناك
هدوءا على الاقل يعني لهذه الدقائق يعني
منذ
دقائق يعني فقط ولكن
منذ الليله الماضيه يعني تعودنا على انه
ما يلبث ان يكون هناك بعض الهدوء ثم نعود
ونسمع لاصوات القذائف واطلاق النار مره
اخرى طيب اعود الى ضيوفي معي
معنى الان من الخرطوم رئيس تحرير منصه
اخبار
واراء محمد شمس الدين استاذ محمد اهلا بك
معنا في هذه التغطيه نعلم اذا اعلم ان
يعني الوضع صعب لديكم في ضوء طبعا من قطاع
الكهرباء كذلك تذبذب خدمه الانترنت وكذلك
طبعا صعوبه الوصول الى معلومات ولكن هل
لديك اي معطيات حول حقيقه قصف
مقر قياده الجيش العامه والفيديو الذي
بثته ونشرته قوات الدعم السريع وقالت انه
لمشاهد لقصف مقر القياده العامه للجيش
السوداني في الخرطوم
اهلا
يعني صحيح
الفيديو
للاستعاده ايران في احد مقرات الدعم في
احد مقرات للقوات المسلحه
الخاص بقياده القوات البريه من حيث
ملامح
يعني
تعجبها الاسوار
هذا المبنى وايضا عن بعد يمكن مشاهده
بالفعل الذين يقتلون في الاحياء المحيطه
نعم
بالمناسبه
عمليات احتراق القدس
الثقيل الذي تعرضت له هذه
المجاوره يعني
القطاعات العسكريه في هذه المنطقه لكن هذه
في داخل
مع القياده العامه وهو بالمناسبه مجمع
كبير محامي او مناطق
المطار وجزء من هذا المطالبه الولايات
الحاليه يتبع العسكريه انه طيب ما دامك
مدام الاستاذ محمد يعني تؤكد بالفعل على
ان الصور التي شاهدناها صور
اشتعال النيران باحد المباني كما قالت
الدعم السريع بانها في مقر قياده الجيش
السوداني انت تؤكد ذلك
كيف يمكن النظر الى هذا يعني انه هل يمكن
القول ان قوات الدعم السريع يعني هي تسيطر
هذا المقر الحيوي ام هي
تقترب من السيطره عليه ام كيف يمكن توصيف
الحاله هناك
يعني
السيطره على هذه المقاطع الخاصه بالقياده
العامه
يتحدث في الاساسي والرئيسي للقوات السريع
خاصه بعد التصريحات من قبل قائمه محمد
حمدان الذي قال بانه
يعني لم يستسلم هذا في المطلق وقال بانه
لابد من ان يجبر القران
بعد تحديد ما قاله
المعارك
مراجعه حرب الشوارع
والحاله الرائده التي وجدتم فيها
بشكل مفاجئ
ايضا على ما يبدو لعده ايام وهناك لابد ان
نشتري اليها
يتعلق بالحاله الانسانيه وقت الممرات
الامنه
المساعدات الانسانيه
والاسعافات الاوليه في الجرحى والمصابين
من كل الاظافر
العسكريه التي تتساقط وهناك نظرات تظهر
يعني
احجام هذه الاصابات والخسائر البشريه
التواصل الاجتماعي
مترجمه منذ ساعه الاولى بان المحاكم
التجاريه
صباحا
لم يفتح ابواضه
هنا ربما تصدر يصدر التذكير بان طبعا
قياده الجيش
طلبت من السكان البقاء في منازلهم واعلنت
اليوم الاحد يعني هو يوم عطله طبعا في ظل
الاقتتال الدائر اذا في مختلف المناطق
وخاصه في المناطق الحيويه
في
العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم
طيب ارجو ان تبقى
نعمات القويه التي ما زالت تطلق باتجاه
مقرات القياده العامه يعني مشاهده اعمده
الدوسان الكتف وهي نازله مستمره جميعا نحن
الان على الهواء نتابع هذا الدخان الذي
تتحدث منه لا اعلم اذا كان بوسعك مشاهده
العربيه
استاذ محمد هذا المبنى الذي تتصاعد منه
يتصاعد منه الدخان هل بوسعك تحديد اذا كان
مقر قياده الجيش
والقصر مستمر الان ايضا شاهدنا للتو قذيفه
اذا تصطدم بهذا المبلغ
محمد لم اتمكن من الاستماع اليك بشكل واضح
هل تسمعني
جيدا نعم اسمعك جيدا هل تؤكد ان هذا
المبنى هو مبنى مقر قياده الجيش محمد
نعم هو احد المقرات الخاصه بالقياده
العامه للجيش يعني مرجح ان يكون مقر قياده
القوات البريه يرجح ان يكون مقر قيمه لا
يمكن بعد
ملامح يعني
لكن اؤكد تماما بان هذه
السنه الدخان في هذه اللحظات هذه
ايضا
ونحن نشاهد الان صوره مقربه للمبنى معك
محمد طبعا كما يرجح ضيفي ان هذا المبنى هو
مقر قوات الدفاع البريه اذا في مقر قياده
الجيش السوداني دخان كثيف يتصاعد والسنه
النيران اذن يعني تلتهم عددا من طوابق هذا
المبنى
طبعا يترافق معها صوت اطلاق الرصاص طبعا
مع بدايه هذا اليوم الثاني من هذه
المواجهه العنيفه والمعارك التي اندلعت
منذ صباح الامس بين المكونين العسكريين
نسمع الان صوت اطلاق الرصاص بكثافه في
ساعات اليوم الثاني الاولى من هذه
المواجهه بين قوات الدعم السريع بقياده
حميتي
والجيش بقياده البرهان
قذيفه اخرى
اذا تتوالى القذائف اذا المشاهدين ان نبدا
هذا اليوم معكم اذا في هذه الساعه مع طبعا
اصوات القذائف التي تعلو واطلاق الرصاص
طبعا والدخان المتصاعد بكثافه والسنه
النيران اذن من هذا المبنى الذي يرجح انه
تابع لمقر قياده الجيش السوداني احد
المقرات الحيويه طبعا التي تقوم قوات
الدعم السريع بقياده محمد حمدان والمعروف
بحمتي
بقصفه طبعا
منذ الليله الماضيه وهو احد مقرات الجيش
السوداني
طبعا في المقابل الجيش السوداني قال انه
طبعا اعاد السيطره على عدد من القواعد
العسكريه التابعه
لقوات الدعم السريع في ام درمان وبانه
استعاد السيطره على مقر الاذاعه
والتلفزيون الذي كانت قوات الدعم السريع
قد سيطرت عليه في وقت سابقا من الامس
ولكن الان مع طبعا بزوغ فجر هذا اليوم
الثاني
وسطوع الشمس النهار يعني يتجدد المشهد
العنيف بشكل قوي جدا ربما بعده ستنجلي
الصوره اذا عما يحصل لعلي هنا استعين
بضيفي محمد شمس الدين من الخرطوم اذن
ومعه نشاهد هذه الصوره من زاويتين
مختلفتين على شاشه العربيه استاذ محمد هل
يمكنك ان تعلق معنا اذا على هذه الصوره
حيث يتصاعد الدخان كذلك من احد الابنيه
على ما يبدو من احد مقرات قياده الجيش في
الخرطوم
نعم صهيب يعني كما كنا نتحدث قبل قليل فان
هذه
الاعمده اعمده الدخان تتصاعد من احد
المقرات التي يعني اشتغلت فيها النيران
قبل قليل كما كنا نتحدث قبل قليل
وما زالت اعمده اللهب يمكن مشاهدتها وكذلك
اعمده الدخان الناجم عن هذا الاحتراق
وهذا بكل تاكيد ناجم عن الاشتباكات
الضاريه التي حدثت قبل قليل ما بين قوات
الدعم السريع
والقوات المسلحه في داخل
المبنى المجاور نعم وشاهدنا الانفجار الان
للتو يعني ولكن محمد هل هل بوسعك ان ترجح
يعني اذا كان هذا القصف يعني او بوسك ان
تؤكد اذا كان هذا القصف من قوات الدعم
السريع
نعم لا توجد يعني قوه اخرى كبيره لديها
النيه للسيطره على هذا المكان سوى قوه
الدعم السريع في المقام الاول ولكن كل
السيناريوهات الاخرى ايضا متاحه وهنا
نتحدث عن سيناريو احتمال يعني تمرد بعض
الفصائل داخل مقر القياده العامه وهذا امر
يعني يعني في هذه اللحظه هو مستبعد لكنه
احد السيناريوهات التي غير الممكن يعني
نحن نشاهد نشاهد اثار الهجوم يعني الذي
كما تفضلت يعني انه المرجح انه هو قوات
الدعم السريع ماذا عن الدفاع عن الجيش ما
المتوافر يعني حول
وضع قوات الجيش في هذا المقر مقر القياده
العامه
يعني
من الوضع تماما ان قياده العمليات في هذه
اللحظات ربما تتم في مواقع اخرى او في
موقع اخر غير مقر القياده العامه للقوات
المسلحه
لكن هناك قطاعات كثيره متواجده في داخل
هذه المنطقه او الاشتباكات تجري بينها
وبين قوات الدعم السريع يعني بشكل مكثف في
على طول المنطقه
المحاذيه او المخصصه
لمنطقه القياده العامه وهي بالمناسبه هي
منطقه محاذيه وملاصقه تماما للمطار حتى ان
القاعده العسكريه هي جزء من هذا المطار
الذي يقع الى الجنوب من مقر القياده
العامه
هناك تحركات لبعض الاليات قبل
ساعات بمجرد اندلاع النيران في هذا المبنى
التابع
للقياده العامه للقوات الاليات التي تتحدث
عنها هي اليات للجيش يعني
لم اسمعك جيدا تحدثت عن اليات تمكنت من
رصدها وهي تتحرك نتحدث عن اليات تابعه
للجيش تقصد للدفاع عن مقر القياده العامه
ام ماذا
نعم صحيح شاهدنا دبابات تتحرك
متجهه نحو مقرات القياده العامه
يعني يمكن ايضا القول بانه هذا التصرف
ربما يكون رد على
يعني ما حدث بالامس من احراق لمقر
الدعم السريع مقر قياده الدعم السريع
المواجهه تماما
لمقر القياده العامه والاشتباكات اصلا
تدور في هذه المنطقه يعني النيران تنطلق
ما بين الطرفين
في هذه المنطقه نعم
اذا محمد ارجو ان تبقى معنا اذا مشاهدينا
المشهد يعني غني عن كل تعليق اذا في هذا
اليوم الثاني من المواجهه العنيفه بين
قوات الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع
الصور من مقر قياده الجيش السوداني في
العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم تشاهدون نتيجه
القصف المتواصل والهجوم العنيف على هذا
المقر
وبالامكان ان
نشاهد ونستمع الان يعني في ساعات الليله
الماضيه كان من الصعب
توضيح الصوره او الرؤيه بوضوح في ظل يعني
الظلام
الدامس او ظلام الليل ولكن الان كنا فقط
كان بوسعنا ان نسمع اصوات القذائف والرصاص
الان بدنا
قادرين على او اصبحنا قادرين على ان نشاهد
وان نسمع يعني هذه نتائج هذه المواجهه
وهذا الهجوم على احد المقرات الحيويه
الرئيسيه
التابعه للجيش السوداني
في هذه المواجهه الخطيره بين المكونين
العسكريين الجيش من جهه بقياده عبد الفتاح
البرهان وقوات الدعم السريع بقياده محمد
حمدان والمعروف في حماتي محمد اسالك كذلك
نحن نراقب اذن هذا المقر الحيوي وهو المقر
القياده قياده الجيش هل من معلومات
متوافره حول وضعيه باقي المقرات الحيويه
اقصدون القصر الجمهوري بالاساس
مقر الاذاعه والتلفزيون وكذلك مطار
الخرطوم
يعني بالنسبه للمطار وهو المحادي لهذه
المنطقه
[موسيقى]
يمكن
المطار يعني
مبدئيا هو معطل عم نرجع للسيطره صحيح
الخارج عن الخدمه يقصد خارج عن الخدمه
فعليا كانت في بدايه الامر هناك حاله
مسيطره عليه من قبل قوات الدعم السريعه
التي دخلت وحتى التقطت بعض اللقطات من
الداخل وهي تتحرك وتجوب صلاه المطار هذا
من الناحيه المتعلقه بالمطار بالنسبه
للتلفزيون ايضا بالامس كانت هناك يعني
مواجهات في مقر التلفزيون
واله السيطره على ما يبدو في نهايه المطاف
الى الدعم الذي احتجز الموظفين في استوديو
البث المباشر لساعات قبل ان يفرج عنهم ومن
ثم احتجز بعض الموظفين في الاذاعه طبعا
المقر الاذاعه والتلفزيون في يعني مجمع
واحد ايضا في ام درمان
هذا فيما يخص الاذاعه والتلفزيون
المقرات الاخرى
الكامله عليها
هذه اللحظه
لما يتعلق مثلا بالقصر القصر بالمناسبه هو
مقر يعني لا يوجد فيه الكثير من التفاصيل
التي يمكن ان تؤثر على المشهد اذا انه
يعني فارغ منذ خلوه مكاتبه من اعضاء او
يعني من تواجد اعضاء مجلس السياده والامور
منذ تلك الفتره كانت تدار من بيت الضيافه
في داخل المجمع الذي يتعرض الان لهذه
المواجهات مجمع
القياده العامه يعني هذا بصوره عامه حول
المقرات الرئيسيه المحيطه او المتواجده في
هذه المنطقه نستمع الى اصوات النيران
بالمناسبه وهي تاتي ايضا من اتجاه
القصر وطبعا من الناحيه الاخرى في الخرطوم
بحري ايضا هناك بعض المقرات العسكريه يعني
الاتجاه ذاته اتجاه الشمال ولكن ولكن محمد
يعني حتى يعني نحاول طبعا ان نقرا الصوره
بحذر نعم نشاهد زاويه اخرى من الشاشه من
مقر قياده الجيش
حيث طبعا نشاهد بوضوح طبعا كذلك السنه
اللهب والدخان المتصاعد الناتج عن القصف
المتواصل الذي تجدد بكثافه في هذه الساعه
كنت اريد ان اسالك محمد يعني حتى نتجلى
الصوره كذلك ونفهم الصوره كذلك
الجيش السوداني كان قال قبل يعني حوالي
الساعه بان
الشعب السوداني سيسمع اخبار طيبه قريبا او
اخبار ساره قريبا هكذا قال ربما هذه
التصريحات تتعارض مع هذه الصوره التي
نشاهدها الان ماذا يحدث كيف يمكن ان نفهم
ما يحصل من هذه الصوره مع بيانات الجيش
يعني يمكن وضع هذا التصريح صهيب في اطار
يعني اطار الحرب المعنويه ايضا التي
اندلعت مع اندلاع هذه الحرب الميدانيه
تماما
بالمناسبه يعني كانت المؤشرات كلها تشير
الى ان الكفه ترجح الى
كافه
القوات المسلحه قوات الجيش الصور التي
ظهرت
من مختلف المواقع والمدن وهي تظهر
المواطنين وهم يلتحمون مع عناصر قوات
الجيش كانت ايضا تشير الى هذا الامر
بين هذا وذاك يعني كنا نشاهد ايضا لقطات
للدعم السريع وهم يقولون بانهم يسيطرون
على بعض المقرات الحيويه وما الى ذلك
حتى ساعات الليل المتاخره كان الامر يعني
يؤشر الى ان السيطره
يعني ترجع لكافه قوات
الجيش لكن على ما يبدو ان هناك مستجدات
وامرا جديدا قد حدث ولا نعلم ما نوع حتى
التسليح الذي ادى الى يعني التمكن من
اختراق كل هذه المسافه
واصابه يعني مقرات
القوات الجيش بهذا العمق يعني او بهذا
الحجم كذلك صحيح
هذا صحيح لانه المنطقه هذه تم ضرب طوق
امني كبير عليها منذ ساعات مبكره فلا احد
يعرف يعني تم حتى ابعاد عناصر قوات الدعم
السريع الى مواقع بعيده الى احد يعرف كيف
حدث هذا الامر ومن اين جاءت هذه القوه
وكيف اخترقت هذه المنطقه اخترقت المطار
واخترقت المنطقه الشرقيه لمقر القياده
العامه
ويعني الكل يتساءل حتى هذه اللحظه
يعني كيف تم هذا الامر صحيح
وما يطرح الاسئله كذلك انه ما الذي اوصل
الامر بين
البرهان
وحمدتي الى هذه
المرحله من الاقتتال في الشارع وفي
العاصمه الخرطوم
الرجلان كان بالامس القريب حليفين بشكل
وثيق
صحيح هذا هو يعني ابرز يعني
التساؤلات او هذه هي ابرز التساؤلات في
يعني اذهننا مختلف المتابعين والمراقبين
خاصه ممن هم من خارج البلاد لكن من يتابع
من الداخل يعرف حجم الخلاف القوي الذي كان
يعني متراكما طوال هذه الفتره ما بين
الرجلين على وجه التحديد وحجم طموحات التي
كانت لدى يعني
الرجلين ايضا
للوصول الى السلطه والبقاء في السلطه هذا
دفع
بالمشهد برمته الى الانفجار في لحظه معينه
لكن الزمن كان مستغربا لدى البعض ولم يكن
مستغرب لدى البعض الاخر فيما يتعلق
بالحديث حول ملف دمج الدعم السريع وهو
الامر الذي كان مرفوضا من قبل
المؤسسه العسكريه
هنا ربما لب العقده محمد يعني لماذا كان
هذا الرفض لدمج قوات الدعم السريع ضمن
الجيش
هذا سؤال
يعني منطقي جدا
الرفض كان ناجما من بعض القطاعات من منطلق
ان هذه القوات لم يعني تتمرس ولم تاخذ
التدريب كما حصلت عليها القوات الشرعيه
وذلك عبر الكليه
الحرب ولم تحصل على التاهيل المطلوب اذا
هذا من ناحيه من ناحيه اخرى فان هناك
دوافع اخرى
مرتبطه
يعني بعض الانتماءات اذ ان هناك من يعتبر
ان لديه ثارا مع قوات حمايه التي يعني
قامت
بالانقلاب على النظام السابق
ورمز نعم
لذلك فان عمليه الرفض كانت
ايضا من هذا
المنطلق من الناحيه الاخرى السيد دقلو
ايضا كان يرفض عمليه الدمج لاسباب عديده
لانه كان يخشى من سيناريوهات مشابهه لهذه
يعرف بان هناك من لا يحبذ وجوده ومن ومن
لن يتفاعل معه بشكل ايجابي لن يمنحه
الموقع الذي يعني يرغب فيه الان من الواضح
تماما بان السيد
يرغب في المنصب الاول هي قصه رفيقين على
ما يبدو تحولا الى عدوين لدودين
وانزلقت الامور بينهما الى هذا الاقتتال
الى هذا المشهد الذي نتابعه الان مباشره
على الشاشه مشاهدينا لم نلتحق بنا اللحظه
هذه صور مقر قياده الجيش السوداني وهو
يتعرض لهجوم عنيف من قبل قوات الدعم
السريع بقياده محمد حمدان دقلو
طبعا
تشاهدون هذا الدخان الكثيف وكذلك اللهب
الذي يلتهم عددا من طوابق احد ابنيه مقر
قياده الجيش السوداني العامه طوال الليله
الماضيه ونحن نسمع اصوات القذائف
واصوات الرصاص كانت هدات قليلا هذه
المواجهات بعض الشيء بعد اذان الفجر
لتتجدد بكثافه وبعنف شديد اذا كما نتابع
معكم الان في هذه الصور شاهدوا الرصاص وهو
طبعا في احد جدران المبنى